look I mean you're already gonna win
this despite being a nice white girl you
know many happy roommate relationships
have been torn asunder over fridge
politics meet Danny and Ari childhood
friends and now adults living together
who can't agree on when to throw food
out in their fridge either way they're
gonna settle it today undebatable
we've been living together for about two
years now
and I mean it's lovely really we've been
friends since we were nine so it says
yes food waste is a big problem in
America Danny doesn't throw in her food
and it rots in the fridge and then he
gets mad at me because I hold it up to
Andrew be like hey you wanna throw
myself you know and I think that that's
just like some privileged [ __ ] she's
just trying to show him you should look
at what you're wasting and look at your
mama Puerto Rico had nothing and you're
wasting this for your daughter
you're saying it with their eyes your
finger with your eyes your baby she's
crazy
that's a ho ass move every time I go
grocery shopping I try to go put food in
the fridge and there's no room because
there's all this dirty food wasted
you're sharing are you should be
considerate and not leave a lot of food
waste that you make your roommate clean
I buy the majority of the groceries no I
don't even share you [ __ ] yeah you do
and I think the licious meals and you I
like them and I make them in the think
now I will take pictures okay that
happens maybe once a month but it's like
this is this myth that keeps being like
blown up that you are going to the
people of America I even came God and
they will believe her too that's great
alright I think that's plenty
I think it's abundantly clear that
neither of you are gonna budge on this
issue so it's time to settle it with a
throwdown behold the Throwdown zone
come along now what you see before you
is going to settle your issue once and
for all
you'll notice the challenge fridge and
over here a wide array of food that you
might find in fridge some of these
excellent ingredients for a smoothie
others not so much
you will have 30 seconds to throw the
items of your choosing into your
designated home Danny you'll have the
top hole Oriole at the bottom hole after
30 seconds the food that lands in your
hole will be placed into a smoothie that
your opponent will have to drink so what
they have to drink is up to you whoever
finishes their smoothie first or drinks
the most of it will be the winner of
this debate is there anything on this
table that particularly appalls either
of you everything all right let's put
the time on the clock and row down that
was my strategy to I don't want to eat
hot cheetos I'm gonna get some peanut
butter it's spinach I don't think I can
throw this part BAM we're not getting up
some sardines oh my god
I like sorry oh you're even 14 pile of
sardis I really enjoyed this in a GMO
pop-tart oh I should have joined Little
League Apple I'm just good at this pleb
corner Rican
no yoghurt okay all right that's that's
point time's up
that's enough how do we feel that went
back to all the food waste well it looks
like you got plenty in there but let's
be honest the things are fighting over
the most are leftovers so let's do a
30-second bonus round swinging the
leftovers Oh God oh yeah beautiful we've
got some leftover trash I think all
we've got some nice Nuggets we've got
french fries we've got pizza
we've got sushi let's put the time on
the clock and throw it out oh my god oh
damn it
you're not happy
the glass did you try to kill me I feel
there was some flagrant disregard of the
rules here we are going to make these
beautiful smoothies and you two are
gonna go head-to-head in a smoothie
chug chug off yeah let's see what we
ended up with here in the top fridge so
this is going to be Ferrari it sorry
now that's a beautiful smoothie oh wow
gorgeous go ahead oh yeah here are your
smoothie in green
Danny smoothie so the expansion pizza I
love that there's also a nice helping of
sardines in there but you did not do
that
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I have a gag reflex problem yeah
maybe you shoulda thought of that before
you didn't throw your food away maybe
you should shut the [ __ ] up so it's like
peanut butter and ranch dressing
I want a smaller nose all mine
oh you're just feels like a green juice
- saw buzzes OH
[Music]
[Music]
I got two sips but oh I got it tastes
like the devil's diarrhea Oh tasted like
ranch dressing and fecal matter I don't
want to look at it oh yeah it's all
right okay
the aftertaste is way bad well great
work you've got a hold - gulps in and
you just started gagging immediately ha
ha ha I already take it away I was right
and I was wrong
art is right I was four huh we'll take
it I will be more vigilant about the
food in the fridge that is rotten and
needs to be thrown out I'll be more
vigilant about the food in the fridge
that is rotten and needs to be thrown
out
well congratulations I'm glad I could
help you settle this matter that's been
debatable Throwdown yeah I tell you for
a video about food waste we sure didn't
get that message across still good
though No